[Music]
they don't call him the Clown Prince of
Crime for nothing well the Joker may be
known for murder and mayhem he's also
you know a joker and no version of the
Joker better showcases his maniacal
mischief better than Mark Hamill's take
on the iconic villain from the beloved
Batman the Animated Series in a show
aimed squarely at kids the gruesome
death and destruction was toned down a
bit in favor of showing the Joker's
ability to break the law and have a good
laugh while doing it so what would it
look like if the animated version of the
Joker had to stand trial in the real
world for his crimes to find out just
what kind of legal trouble the Joker
would be looking at we needed to consult
with a legal expert my name is Doug
Ridley I'm a criminal defense attorney I
run my own law firm and I started out my
career as a prosecutor in the district
attorney's office in the episode The
Laughing fish The Joker dumps toxins
into the Gotham River to give all the
fish his signature smile this seems like
a pretty big environmental no now
potentially dumping into a river is an
environmental crime it's an
environmental offense
I guess arguably harming the fish would
be something that a prosecutor would
want to go on as well if Mark Hamill's
Joker was punished for the environmental
impacts that he did then I would imagine
that would be fines and some sort of
restitution for the cleanup I prosecuted
a case early in my career where a
trucking company had dumped some oil
into a riverbed and so in that case we
made the trucking company pay for any
cost of cleanup the environmental damage
there were a lot of reports that came in
in order to establish that I could see
that being something that Mark Hamill's
Joker would need to do after trying to
create his Joker fish is there any way
you could see the Joker finding a legal
loophole to get himself off the hook I
actually would spend a whole lot of time
successfully defending Mark Hamill's
Joker really what he was doing was he
was genetically modifying animals which
is no different than having cows that
have an increase milk supply or
fish that end up living longer or grow
faster I would argue the GMO animal
defense that he did absolutely nothing
criminal in his case corporations now
we're at a point where genetically
modified foods and genetically modified
animals are a thing that science is
creating that companies are spending
lots of money on I'm gonna argue in
front of a jury that Mark Hamill's Joker
was just decades before his time in the
GMO world and that he really was going
in and trying to improve the fish that
were in the Gotham River well some may
say he's an innovator it's hard to
forget the reign of terror that Joker
has caused in Gotham City does having a
history of using deadly toxins for
nefarious purposes worked against him in
this case
a lot of cases Joker's prior acts would
become one of the major prosecution
points that we would have they would
want to bring in all of his bad stuff to
show his pattern and practice of
behavior over time and to also show his
intent my job for the jury is going to
be focusing them in and pulling them
back in also objecting and stopping the
prosecutor from bringing in the prior
acts which is an issue that comes into
play in a lot of cases I am going to do
my best with a straight face to argue to
the jury that he is turning things
around at this point and he is doing a
business of improving the Joker fish
which I can almost do with a straight
face if we're gonna say that the
companies that modify fish to make them
larger are doing something positive for
the world but this one that puts a smile
on the face is somehow wrong I think
that that is a difficult thing to attach
criminal liability to but there's
another legal twist in this case the
Joker is usually going against the law
but in this episode he tries to use the
law to his advantage by busting into a
Copyright Office and claiming a
copyright claim on the genetically
modified fish since every fish in Gotham
now bears my famous and frankly fabulous
I should be getting a profit from every
fish product so it's a bold strategy but
it begs the question can you actually
copyright a fish I can't say
definitively that you can or can't
copyright a fish has chickens and they
don't even have now here's the thing is
that the copyright aspect of the fish
probably isn't protected a copyright we
see four four marks and things on paper
but the idea behind the fish the genetic
formula for the gas that turned the fish
from normal into their smiley brilliance
all of that is potentially scientific
procedures and mechanisms that do have
some level of intellectual property
protection so I would argue that that
process can be protected maybe not the
same way that the Joker had but with me
as his attorney by his side I would have
got him some sort of protection for sure
and a good lawyer might be all the Joker
needs to walk away from this caper with
absolutely no jail time out of all the
Joker cases that we're looking at this
is one that I that I would have a very
good shot at resolving although part of
the reason why I think I could resolve
this case is because I feel pretty
strongly at the end of the day that if a
prosecutor wouldn't give me what I
wanted I would make them put this case
in front of a jury and see what they
would do I would use the phrase Joker
fish as often as possible to make fun of
the prosecution's case and get the jury
to go with me about the fact that this
really wasn't at the end of the day an
environmental disaster like the
prosecution would depict it to be but
really just an early attempt at GMO nice
scheme so maybe it's not the worst crime
the Joker has ever committed and
best-case scenario it might turn out he
didn't even commit a crime at all
still you might want to think twice
about ordering sushi if you ever find
yourself in Gotham
Great Scott actually I'm Irish
[Music]